83-year-old Nancy Pelosi currently
alive CU we're taping this posted on X
today that she will run for reelection
in
2024 but she says now more than ever San
Fran needs her to advance their City's
values and further their
recovery so there you have it an
83-year-old running it again but if she
and people like Feinstein and fedman
McConnell and Biden or what we have
running the country and they can't even
pull together one working brain
cell then Republicans should go even
older nominate the leaders we love who
are
[Laughter]
dead Ronald
Reagan George HW Abe Lincoln why not
what's the difference between them and
the current slate of politicians we got
they may be dead but they're great those
others are dead and they
suck all
right d David uh what's your take on
this why is it just because America
doesn't even know who she is they could
keep running
forever yeah I don't understand it's
like they they the people running this I
I don't know even know if it's they're
all these elderly brain damaged people
that are running I think those are like
they're just Meat Puppets for these Gen
X Insidious you know like back room
Shadow government people but I will say
about Nancy Pelosi it's like you know
she might be the best option out of
California yeah when you think about it
yeah like she's like considered
rightwing out there yeah she's like the
Ron Paul of California yeah so you don't
have her who knows what kind yeah
there's nothing there anymore you you
know Janice when asked if you wanted
Nancy to spend more time around the
house Paul Pelosi said I need that like
a hole in the head oh no no no I'm just
quoting the news people just quoting
what you saw oh yeah yeah now this might
not be now this not might not be true
Janice but whoever wrote this and gave
this to me we're meeting
afterwards no but it's true don't you
don't you think that like it it it's so
we like why not elect dead people well
what's the point we're we're electing
dead people now but it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if you're a Republican or
a Democrat just these elderly people
need to ride off into the sunset she's
got right I mean I would I would she has
lots of money tons of money a a freezer
full of that expensive ice cream she
likes to get her hair done you know just
have a nice rest of your life why do you
want to go go back into that I don't
know they should replace the Department
of Education with the Department of
Visiting
Angels Visiting Angels cat well yeah
they're America's Choice in home care
they yes they really are they really are
they're almost as popular as the people
that put those new bathtubs in your over
your old disgusting one I sometimes
think you should do that with your
relatives cat
um I I don't know some yeah take it why
isn't anybody pulling these people aside
and saying come on go to bed no I yeah I
I don't I I wouldn't want to be the one
look to do that I think that what she's
doing here kind of makes sense it's very
like fifth year senior Vibes yeah cuz
she was the speaker but now she wants to
do like another year where like maybe
the classes are a little easier but she
just
like right she gets to keep like hanging
out and hanging on to what she knows and
maybe she be walking around giving
everybody advice you know and everyone's
like hey like you're still here what are
you doing here yeah but she has the
money so why not yeah it is but she has
the money she does go away yes but you
can't Insider trade if you're on the
outside that's
[Applause]
true yeah that's ay you know when they
do those little meme quotes on Twitter
which is now X that should be the one
you can't inside training on the outside
it says Greg Gutfeld or no it says
Gutfeld show
host he's getting a little long in the
tooth too while
you all right walk in the
forest um terce what do we do what do we
do I don't know ter you the size of a
terce see I mentioned you start falling
apart listen first of all you know
Janice I always support you but how dare
you you said ride off in the sunset you
know Dam well they can't ride nothing
off the sun unless it's a power little
scooter that's it yeah that's it that's
number one listen Maybe we're looking at
this wrong maybe these are all cool
superpowers they have you know like
President Biden talks to dead people
awesome Mitch McConnell goes to the
[Laughter]
Matrix you know and Nancy she turns into
Wall Street so yeah it's sad though
because you know what's going to happen
they're all going to die on the job but
yet we'll still vote for three months
right exactly so yeah Feinstein we
haven't seen it on both Kennedy McCain
literally died still voting yeah like he
was on his deathbed and got the thumb up
like yeah that's right that's right he
us up and I love the man I thought he he
was a great American hero but it's too
long yeah it's too long I've heard that
before Jesus what with his conversations
I'm talking know how to end anything
when he's passionate that fou of stuff
was maybe 5 minutes he TCH it to 15 I
was talking about the theatrical I'm
covering for you you're blowing it here
I'm talking about Lawrence of Arabia if
you watch it in the theaters it's too
long this conversation is too long yes
but I do I I love long movies I prefer
them uncut yeah at least three and a
half
got good uncut
film yeah all right up next nothing
could be better than reading a Fan's
letter hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else